ja ich begrüße ganz herzlich zu dieser
tagung mit dem titel geisteswissenschaft
was bleibt und dann eine alliteration
zwischen theorie tradition und
transformation an diesem schönen tag
hier in münchen und könnte sicherlich
noch besseres machen als sie in einem
schattigen raum zu sitzen aber morgen
wird das wetter ja nicht mehr so schön
werden als morgen wird man es nicht
bereuen ich glaube auch nicht dass es
irgendjemand bereuen werden müsste hier
gewesen zu sein ich glaube wir haben
sehr spannendes programm ich will
vorwerk ist ein paar punkte sagen zur
anlage dieser tagung der titel dieser
tagung lautet geisteswissenschaft fast
bleibt und als ich mal ein bisschen
recherchiert hat bin ich auf ein buch
gestoßen was im jahr 2003 erschienen ist
mit dem titel wozu geisteswissenschaften
das ist ein sammelband und er versteht
sich als kontroverse argumente für eine
überfällige debatte und in der
beschreibung dieses bandes dem campus
verlag erschienen ist heißt es nicht
jedes mal vor
selbstbeschreibung zitat wer sich heute
in der öffentlichkeit als
geisteswissenschaftler zu erkennen gibt
der verfügt längst nicht mehr über das
prestige eines studien rates oder
doktors der philosophie wie im bildungs
beflissen 19 jahrhundert stattdessen
macht vielfach das zynische wort vom
promovierten taxifahrer die runde
dessen studium in dazu befähigt seinem
fahrgast mit zwar geistreicher jedoch
zweckfreie konversation die zeit zu
vertreiben
die im frühjahr 2003 in hamburg
angestoßene hochschulreform hat indessen
weitreichende konsequenzen für die
geisteswissenschaften stellen werden
reduziert förderungsmittel gestrichen
und forderungen nach mehr ökonomische
effizienz erhoben mit den bedürfnissen
des arbeitsmarktes wird argumentiert das
war mehr hochschulabsolventen natur und
wirtschaftswissenschaften braucht
weniger in den geistes- und
kulturwissenschaften die beiträge dieses
bandes liefern aus unterschiedlichen
bereichen der gesellschaft
repräsentative meinungen über sinn und
zweck der geisteswissenschaft zu beginn
des einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts was
sind ihre aufgaben
und wie können sie diesen gerecht werden
ziehen sie in einer modernen
gesellschaft unverzichtbar und sollen
auch an den hochschulen von morgen
geisteswissenschaftliche disziplin stark
vertreten sein
auch die geisteswissenschaften müssen
sich die frage gefallen lassen was sie
für die gegenwärtige kultur und
gesellschaft leisten
das war diese debatte vor 15 jahren und
es möglich noch einen schritt weiter in
die vergangenheit gehen die 80er jahre
da erschien ein buch von friedrich
kittler mit dem titel sammelband
austreibung des geistes aus den
geisteswissenschaften
ich würde auch ein paar zitate bringen
aus der einleitung dieses landes es gab
gibt nach kittner drei austragungen des
geistes nämlich die austreibung des
geistes des menschen und der geschichte
und zwar in verschiedenen
konstellationen zunächst sagte die
kombination von geist und mensch ist
ohne belang bei der analyse eines
wissens dass alle leute haben ohne dass
noch einmal wissen zu müssen
in diese lücke der geisteswissenschaften
das unbewusste tritt mit den studien
über hysterie 18 95 die psychoanalyse
freuds zweiter punkt die kombination von
geist und geschichte ist ohne belang bei
einer menge von sprach tatsachen die
allen laut wandel geschichten und
sprecher wünschen zum trotz bohren und
münder zu differenz anhalten
in diese lücke tritt mit skoda
langfristige general von 1915 die
linguistic des signifikanten und zu
guter letzt die kombination drittens von
geschichte und mensch ist ohne belang
bei lebensformen die schon aussterben
wenn die geschichte mit kanonenbooten
vor ihren stränden auch nur anker wird
und diese lücke ist seit frasers
totenmesse namics ag von 1910 eine an
historische ethnologie getreten wenn es
also tatsächlich so wäre dass der geist
aus den geisteswissenschaften vertrieben
wurde
dann müsste man auf die frage dieser
tagung geisteswissenschaft was bleibt
natürlich antworten nicht so gut wie
nichts dem ist aber glaube ich nicht der
fall
und ganz im gegenteil diese tagung
möchte versuchen zu klären was überhaupt
geisteswissenschaften ist und was
überhaupt geist ist von dem es eine
geisteswissenschaft geben soll
eine weitere frage die wir uns hier
stellen wollen gemeinsam ist die frage
ob geisteswissenschaft überhaupt einen
mannschaft ist natürlich schließt sich
da die frage an was eine wissenschaft
überhaupt ist dann die spannende frage
die mich persönlich sehr interessiert
und zu der ich mir schon sehr viele
gedanken gemacht habe ist philosophie
überhaupt einen da ist dass wissenschaft
oder eine wissenschaft was ist
philosophie überhaupt wie manifestiert
sich geistiges medium der schrift und
geschichte und wie kann es verstanden
werden
weitere fragen wie verhalten sich
naturwissenschaft und
geisteswissenschaft zueinander andere
frage in welchem verhältnis stehen
geisteswissenschaft und
kulturwissenschaft und zum schluss wie
kann geisteswissenschaft digital
betrieben werden das sind also nur
einige der fragen die wir uns laufe der
heutigen und morgigen tages stellen
wollen wir wollen also diese fundamente
der geisteswissenschaften behandeln die
in diesen zwei genannten publikationen
in meinen augen ein bisschen zu kurz
kamen wollen also die bedingungen der
möglichkeit von geisteswissenschaften
klären und aus verschiedenen
perspektiven behandelt